Alain aage le maire de la verrière est
avec nous sur ce plateau pour évoquer
ses projets pour sa commune mais déjà un
mot sur votre style peut-être on ne peut
pas éviter la comparaison avec Pierre
sénincour votre prédécesseur qui est
resté pendant plus d'une vingtaine
d'années maire de cette commune est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment d'exercer
différemment cette fonction de de maire
de la commune oui indéiablement si on en
avait d'ailleurs longuement parlé avec
Pierre sellincour au moment du
changement voilà on n'est pas de la même
génération évidemment et puis une autre
peut-être une autre approche une autre
culture une autre temporalité dans
l'exercice du mandat donc forcément un
autre style et une autre manière de de
de concevoir la projection de la ville
par exemple dans l'avenir forcément et
par rapport aux différentes choses que
vous avez pu mettre en place on parle de
ce style visite d'un quartier une fois
par mois par exemple vous rendez
régulièrement visite aux habitants vous
allez voir comment comment ils vivent
dans cette commune B je suis nouveau
maire donc forcément j'ai une obligation
d'aller au devant des des des citoyens
c'est ceci d'une obligation tout à fait
agréable et donc j'ai tout un ensemble
de de de rendez-vous avec la population
dont les visites de quartiers que je
fais régulièrement dans tous les
quartiers de la ville où je retourne
également et où je suis accueilli où on
discute on regarde un petit peu les les
choses du quotidien mais les choses du
quotidien sont des éléments essentiels
de la vie de tous les jours il y aura
des rencontres avec ces verrièrois
verrièroise également du 12 au 25
novembre comment ça va s'organiser j'ai
prévu neuf temps de rencontrre avec les
élus de la ville donc neuf moments
particuliers pour rencontrer à la fois
les habitants des quartiers dans les
quartiers mais aussi rencontrer les
jeunes rencontrer les personnes plus
âgées rencontrer les les responsables
d'association rencontrer les acteurs
économiques donc d'avoir tout un un
ensemble de de réunions qui sont des des
réunions de travail des réunions de
réflexion des réunions d'écoute et des
réunions de partage hein puisque j'ai
aussi des informations à donner
évidemment aux habitants et puis j'ai à
recueillir tout un ensemble d'aprs
appréciation d'inquiétude d'attente
quelles sont ces inquiétudes justement
quelles sont les demandes que vous
pouvez avoir depuis 6 mois je crois que
la première chose c'est que les les
verriè rois tout comme les Français sont
inquiets hein il a un sentiment
d'inquiétude profond s le rend s'en rend
compte sentiment d'inquiétude face à la
dégradation des conditions de vie he
sociales les inquiétudes vis-à-vis de
l'avenir de même pour leurs enfants pour
leurs petits- enfants quand il s'agit
d'ancien de la ville et donc il faut
essayer de non pas de de les rassurer à
tout prix mais de leur montré
qu'effectivement la ville est à leur
côté les élus sont là les services sont
présents et donc il y a une grande
attente sur la capacité de nos servic de
développer des actions qui les
accompagnent tout au long de la
rencontre de ces difficultés par exemple
la commune de laavrière c'est la
deuxième commune la plus pauvre du
département des ivelines comment vous
pouvez agir concrètement pour remédier à
à une telle situation c'est pas un
palmarès dont on est particulièrement
fier lorsqu'on émer j'imagine alors
c'est pas la commune qui est la plus
pauvre ce sont les ressources des
habitants les revenus des habitants bah
pas fier ou moi je pas non les
verrièrois sont ce qu'ils sont et c'est
pas parce qu'ils ont les revenus faibles
qu'ils déméritent par rapport aux autres
donc je suis au contraire très fier de
cette population verrièroise pourant
j'imagine que vous voulez les tirer
plutôt vers le haut on aimerait
effectivement que il puisse retrouver
des parcours d'ascension sociale que ça
soit dans leur parcours professionnel de
formation ou ou d'habitat donc c'est
effectivement tout ce qu'on est en train
de construire avec eux pour l'avenir
parce qu'il y a un sentiment de fatalité
qui peut s'installer aussi chez ses
administrés de de se dire voilà on fait
part on a des ressources faibles est-ce
que vu le contexte on va réussir à s'en
sortir pas forcément comment la mairie
peut agir quelles sont les actions que
vous pouvez mettre en place pour les
aider je crois on a deux responsabilités
la première c'est à travers lesécoutes
citoyennees de montrer que rien n'est
écrit rien n'est acquis et
qu'effectivement avec les élus avec les
associations avec les les habitants on
peut revendiquer se battre revendiquer
des droits se battre pour des droits
nouveaux et donc ça c'est important de
sentir que il y a pas de fatalité
effectivement puis la deuxième c'est
tout le travail sur l'avenir que l'on
construit à travers le maintien des serv
serv par exemple he c'est une de mes
priorités les services publics sont
aujourd'hui au bord pour certains du
départ de la fermeture des restrictions
donc il faut se battre pour les les
garder voir les développer pour certains
et puis effectivement à travers le le
projet de développement de la ville
offrir des nouvelles réponses des
nouvelles solutions en terme de
formation d'emploi de transport de
qualité de vie est-ce qu'il y a une
attention aussi particulière qui est
portée sur la prévention de la
délinquence c'est un autre sujet mais
parfois pauvreté va de perd avec avec
délinquence un conseil communal de de
prévention de la délinquence pourrait
voir le
jour il il existe il existe on l'a réuni
dernièrement en présence du préfet
d'ailleurs des ivelines et effectivement
on s'attache à cette question d'ailleurs
il y a pas de lien entre pauvreté
délinquence il y a de la délinquence
colleblanc dans les quartiers up il y a
d'autres formes de délinquence ici il y
a effectivement des situations
difficiles et ces situations difficiles
peuvent conduire à à des comportements
dérivants ou à ou à des pratiques
d'incivilité il faut traiter tout cela
faut être très très attentif notamment
les trafics par exemple de stupéfiants
auqu il faut être attentif ou bien les
agressions contre les personnes même si
la verrière est plutôt une ville
globalement calme la population attend
de son maire aussi que sur ces questions
il soit actif est-ce qu'il y a certains
quartiers où l'accent va être mis
justement sur cette difficulté on a la
présence de la gare qui est la deuxième
gare la plus importante de de
Saint-Quentin donc forcément la présence
d'une gare
attire des AT ement ou des trafics
divers donc c'est plutôt autour de ces
questions que nous allons agir et
comment vous allez mettre en place c'est
quoi c'est des réunions avec ces jeunes
des dialogues mise en place de lieu de
vie aussi peut-être des des des des
attentions particulières sur ces
choseslà moi je crois fortement à ce que
on fasse conjuguer plusieurs actions je
crois pas à la répression à tout crain
je ne crois pas qu'il faille non plus
rester à attendre que les choses se
passent faut être actif et donc faut
agir sur plusieurs dans plusieurs
directions et donc on a effectivement
réfléchi à cela dialogue toujours
toujours toujours et de manière
incessante le dialogue ne jamais rompre
le dialogue avec qui que ce soit et puis
deuxièmement trouver effectivement des
lieux d'occupation pour les jeunes qui
sont quelquefois désœuvrés qui s'
troupent se rassemblent dans des lieux
où ils ont pas forcément la place où
c'est pas le lieu pour le faire et puis
troisièmement travailler avec la police
effectivement sur les actions de
répression quand il y a des conduites
qui ne sont pas tolérables qui sont
dérivantes vis-à-vis de laalliance
jamais la répression seule mais la
répression tout de même oui bien
bien sûr que non bien sûr que non on est
dans un pays droit il faut que les lois
s'appliquent et les jeunes le
comprennent bien la population comprend
bien quand on discute avec les jeunes
ils savent bien qu'ils ont tout intérêt
effectivement à ce que le droit soit
respecté ça leur permet de de vivre
d'ailleurs plus tranquillement la vie et
la vie on va juste faire une petite
pause écouter ces habitants de La
Verrière nous allons les écouter à
propos de leurs attentes pour leur
communes moi je suis dans la zone
pavillonnaire bon tout va pour le mieux
si j'aimerais bien qu'onasse un un petit
peu les routes ben on attend notre ville
plus d'appartements accessibles et puis
un peu plus de soutien envers les
associations plus de travail surtout
quoi on attend des services publics on
les a eu on avait on avait un besoin de
d'un petit un petit guichet pour tirer
de l'argent on l'a eu franchement en
terme de besoins la ville elle nous
apporte ce qu'on a besoin le nécessaire
que la ville soit plus propre oui
quelque chose de particulier j'habite
une mes
et j'aimerais bien que maintenant il ne
fasse plus des maisons sur 100 m car de
terrain qui laisse un petit peu de
verdure c'est quand même agréable et
puis que les travaux dans les rues
soient finis des animations pour les
enfants ça manque je dirais qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses pour ce qui est
loisir mais pour ce qui est recherche
d'emploi insertion ça manque encore un
peu on a une entreprise comme valaleo
qui est une grosse entreprise le
président dernièrement il y était et je
connais pas beaucoup de gens habitant à
la verrière qui travaillent à valaleo
peut-être c'est un paradoxe ou je sais
pas donc peut-être plus de partenariat
entre les entreprises qui sont à la
verrière et les jeunes ou les ou les
habitants de La Verrière voilà alors ça
c'est peut-être une bonne idée je voyez
écouter avec attention la dernière
proposition plus de partenariat avec ses
entreprises Valéo par exemple assez peu
de verrière il travaille oui très peu
alors Valéo c'est une entreprise de
recherche un centre de recherche et
développement avec beaucoup de très haut
niveau de qualification mais j'ai
rencontré dernièrement un groupe de
jeunes à la verrière et eux-mêm ont fait
cette proposition en disant il faudrait
qu'on puisse être plus en liaison avec
les entreprises on va l'organiser
prochainement on va rencontrer les les
les responsables des ressources humaines
par exemple et regardz comment les
entreprises peuvent au moins accueillir
des stagiaires au moins des stagiaires
hein des contrats de qualification des
contrats de formation qu'est-ce qui
freine ces entreprise à l'heure actuelle
ben je crois qu'une situation générale
d'abord peut-être une coupure c'est vrai
que ces entreprises se situent souvent
de l'autre côté de la route enfin pas la
voie ferrée pardon et donc peut-être une
coupure voilà faut qu'on recrée du li
bien peut-être des décalages
sociologiques fort entre les attentes de
notre population son niveau de formation
ses attentes en termees de formation et
d'emploi et le niveau de qualification
né enmins il y a des verrièrois qui sont
employés la MGEN emploie beaucoup de
verrièroi Eurovia emploie des verrièrroi
Intermarché emploie des verrièrrois donc
il y a quand même un lien un des
critères d'ailleurs pour l'installation
de ce petit centre commercial on va
parler de l'urbanisme forcément c'est
important le développement de cette
ville de de la verrière qui va se lancer
depuis 40 ans il n'y avait pas eu de
construction et il y en aura
prochainement on a tout de même entendu
dans le microrottoir une ville plus
propre j' vous faire réagir à ça la
ville de laavrière n'est pas assez
propre je je pense qu' une ville peut
toujours être plus propre la verrière
est une ville propre ça en même temps
c'est une ville qui comprend de grands
ensembles
HLM la propreté est une question
compliquée dans les ensembles HLM faut
ramasser régulièrement les ordions
managires il faut faut traiter les
trottoirs faut traiter les espaces de
jeu donc tout cela demande effectivement
des moyens et puis tout cela reprendre
des charges aussi pour les locataires
hein donc il faut pouvoir équilibrer
entre la prévention l'anim tion qu'on
peut faire pour le respect des espaces
par exemple pour que ça ne pèse pas trop
sur les charges des locataires notre
ville est quand même globalement propre
voilà pour la répon à cet habitant de La
Verrière qu'on a entendu il y a quelques
instants développement de l'urbanisme à
présent l'écoquartier des bécanes
concertation en novembre avec les
habitants première opération 82
logements au bois de l'étan le chantier
va débuter 2013 exactement exactement
c'est ça c'est une grande joie de
pouvoir effectivement s'attaquer à
l'offre de logement même si le contexte
est un peu difficile sur le plan
national mais 82 logements la promotion
est ouverte les verrierois semblent
intéressés en tout cas se sont rendus
nombreux sur le site pour consulter et
remettre des dossiers donc maintenant
c'est ouvert en priorité justement à ces
habitants de la varrière bien sûr les
verrièrois ont été informés
prioritairement je les ai réunis il ét
très nombreux d'ailleurs être venus à la
Réunion et nous leur avons donné un
temps de réaction voilà pour qu'ils
puissent faire part de leur intérêt et
c'est accessible justement en fonction
des ressources parce qu'on évoquait tout
à l'heure c'est ces ressources faibles
des habitants de La Verrière tout le
monde ne pourra pas pas accéder c'est un
parcours donc aujourd'hui certains
devront encore attendre mais nous avons
l'offre la moins chère de 501 en iveline
nous avons une offre comparable à ce au
prix de sortie de trappp par exemple qui
a une TVA à 7 % et donc on essae
effectivement de se situer sur une note
accessible et en plus avec un gros
dispositif d'accompagnement par le
promoteur et par la ville pour que les
gens non seulement achètent mais
puissent payer et rester dans leur
logement l'entretenir et il vivre bien
c'est pas le seul chantier il va y avoir
des
d'aut encore à venir sur cette ville de
La Verrière le quartier des bécan
exactement enfin oui alors
toutèss que cesé 30 ans que nous parlons
du des bécanes alors les choses ont
effectivement évolué elles ont évolué
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a une maîtrise
en partie du du foncier donc
on une maîtrise publique du foncier puis
nous avons avec la communauté
d'agglomération et nos partenaires dont
l'État qui s'est engagé avec une
implication forte du sous-préfet sur
cette question nous nous engageons
effectivement au deux enclavement à
l'aménagement et nous avons nous sommes
en cours de désignation des équipes de
maîtrise d'œuf donc c'est un grand
moment parce que c'est ce sont des
équipes d'urbaniste d'architectes de
paysagistes qui vont travailler à
l'élaboration de ce quartier et à lui
donner vie hein on passe d'un terrain
d'un projet d'un rêve peut-être et
maintenant on va passer à une étape
concrète où avec les verrièrois nous
allons concevoir la réponse aux attentes
des verrièrois mais pas seulement on
accueillera d'autres gens on continue à
regarder un petit peu les les projets
qui attendent les verrièreois les
habitants de cette commune de la
verrière des projets que vous avez prévu
pour eux on a parlé des logements on
peut peut-être s'intéresser aussi à
cette question de la gare il était
question il y a déjà plusieurs mois voir
plusieurs années d'une refondte de tout
ce pôlegard des accès également
doublement du du du pontchouleur aussi
qui permet d'y accéder ceux qui
emprintent ce pont pas forcément les
verrièrois mais tous les habitants
presque de 50 aneline passe un moment
oou un autre par ce pont et il le
constate c'est difficile de circuler il
y a des aménagements qui vont avoir lieu
est-ce qu'une concertation est en court
aussi avec la ville de morpa puisque
c'est la liaison entre ces deux communes
alors d'abord ce ce projet est inclus
dans le projet global des bécanes donc
l'équipe d'urbaniste qui va travailler
va reprendre les études existantes pour
faire le lien entre ce quartier gare et
le quartier d'habitat puisque nous
souhaitons effectivement développer de
l'activité économique par exemple sur
face à la gare mais on veut aussi
faciliter tous les accès notamment le
pontchouleur mais aussi le carrefour de
la malmedonne mais aussi la liaison par
le passage sous la gare sous la ligne de
chemin de fer pour atteindre la verrière
avec le passage des bus qui pourront
plus tard aller sur la partie sud de la
ville donc là il y a un grand un gros
travail qui est engagé et avec l'appui
effectivement du sous-préfet des
premiers financements avec ceux de la
casquille sont Takis pour réaliser une
première tranche d'aménagement du du
transport en site propre hein pour venir
fluidifier les circulations près de la
gare et le dialogue se fait avec cette
commune de morpa également bien sûr on
s'est rencontré on va se revoir avec
George Mougeot mais aussi avec Monsieur
paayux hein le maire de cogier puisque
la commune est limitrophe donc il faut
qu'on regarde tout cela pour que les les
habitants Riverin mais il y a aussi
l'encour Qui est concerné donc les les
habitants des communes riveraines
puissent y trouver aussi leur intérêt
compatible avec ceux de la ville
évidment vous rencontrez vous échangez
mais est-ce que des solutions concrètes
peuvent voir le jour vont voir le jour
est-ce que c'est un dialogue de Sour ou
est-ce qu'il y a des des échanges
concrets qui ont lieu ah non c'est nous
sommes des des pragmatiques j'ai le
sentiment en tout cas que avec les
maires environnant nous sommes des
pragmatiques nous nous essayons de
trouver des solutions concrètes nous
sommes inquiets de voir qu'effectivement
il y a quand même nous avons eu quelqu
nouvelle un peu inquiétante par exemple
du conseil régional avec la ligne C du
RER qui ne figurait plus dans le dans le
zrif les financements du TCSP qui ne
sont pas complètement assurés donc tout
ça ce sont des sujets d'inquiétude à
lever transport en site popre et puis la
ligne la ligne C aussi la ligne C on va
peut-être s'y attarder justement je vous
interromps parce qu'on va être pris par
le temps mais pour conclure cette ligne
C du RER un prolongement jusqu'à la ver
hier était envisagé devait pouvait voir
le jour lerif c'est le schéma
d'aménagement régional qui mettrait fin
à cet aménagement possible c'est pas
tout à fait mais en tout cas le
SDRIF le SDRIF ne dit pas que ce projet
sera réalisé dans les années à venir on
sent
qu'effectivement la priorité pour les
investissements ne semble pas porter sur
cet investissement qui pourtant
indispensable faut qu'on soit cohérent
avec ce qu'on veut on veut du logement
on veut de l'emploi pour avoir du
logement et de l'emploi il faut pouvoir
avoir des circulations douce et donc à
faciliter les transports en commun par
exemple et les aménagements qui
permettent la création de ses logements
merci Alain ja d'être venu sur ce
plateau maire de La Verrière pour faire
le point sur ces différents chantiers ce
qui attend les verrièreroi et les
verrièrois si vous voulez revoir cet
entretien dans son intégralité je vous
renvoie vers notre site Internet vous
pouvez consulter également toutes nos
émissions cette séquence sera en ligne à
partir de demain matin merci à vousci
autre invité de ce 30 octobre à
retrouver dans quelques instants
l'association fly and kist pour parler
aviation et solidarité un écologue
également pour parler éconstruction et
le responsable événementiel du Central
Fred de dev à voisin le Bretonneux qui
nous dira que oui on peut encore avoir
peur d'Halloween l'association alliance
Vita a organisé des happning dans 75
villes dont une qui a fait grand bruit
du côté de Marseille ses adhérents
étaient également à trappe pour dire non
à l'adoption par les couples homosexuel
reportage François chevalier est père de
famille avec sa femme ils ont adopté
deux enfants à la DAS de Paris il y a 10
et 7 ans l'adoption est un thème qu'il
connaît bien nous on vit avec nos
enfants au quotidien et on voit tout ce
qui se passe dans leur tête enfin tout
ce qui nous exprime ce que ne voit pas
forcément même les gens de notre
entourage proche hein donc tout ce qui a
trait à la souffrance de la séparation
et ensuite tout ce qui a trait à
l'identité mais nous on le on le on le
reçoit en pleine tripe quoi à chaque
fois perte de repères conflit d'identité
question sur leur origine pour François
chevalier c'est un vrai traumatisme que
vivent les enfants adoptés ceux qui sont
en droit d'attendre c'est d'avoir un
papa et une maman comme ils on rêv
deavir et rêver enfin de de pouvoir
vivre avec leurs parents d'origine à
l'époque donc tous les enfants vous moi
on est issu d'un père et d'une mère donc
pour c'est essentiel de savoir qu'on est
nous les représentants de cette de ce
couple père et
mère
papa au mardi dernier François Chevalier
a soutenu l'association alliance Vita
venu manifester à trappe contre
l'homoparentalité cette association se
veut solidaire des plus fragiles et
place l'enfant au cœur de ses
préoccupations un projet de loi
souhaite ouvrir la possibilité du
mariage et de l'adoption aux personnes
de même sexe et nous en sommes très
inquiets parce que nous pensons qu'un
enfant confié à l'adoption a besoin d'un
papa et d'une maman un enfant confié à
l'adoption n'a pas le choix on va lui
imposer deux papas ou deux mamans et cet
enfant fragile et sans voix ne peut pas
se défendre et dire qu'il a besoin de
cette
pour se construire des rassemblements
identiques ont été organisés dans 75
villes de France outre trappe
l'association a investi trois autres
villes des ivelines selon alliance Vita
près de 500 personnes se sont
rassemblées à Versailles plus de 200 à
Saint-Germain en lait à Rambouillet 130
personnes auraient participé à la
manifestation contre
l'homoparentalité